so i'm gonna make this video for the
ladies
um even though my channel is mostly for
men
so i think only men are gonna watch it
but this is genuinely
like advice i have for the ladies so if
you're a girl
that constantly says i hate mad men are
trash that sort of thing
you realize what you're communicating um
to matt if you openly say that
you're saying the men that i choose to
date
are trash and you're saying like men
or i allow men to treat me like trash
and you're also saying
that i have been burned and i am
hurt and i'm gonna take it out on you so
just my two cents um i think every
person
at their life at some point has been
burned but if you're gonna take it out
on an entire gender i don't think you
would really appreciate it
if every time like a guy gets cheated on
or a guy has a bad experience with a
woman they say like
women are trash women are [ __ ] women or
whatever like you really wouldn't like
that
so like genuinely
i think we should retire that phrase i
don't think we should say it anymore
i don't know just my two cents but let
me know if you agree or you disagree in
the comments
don't forget to subscribe i'll talk to
you guys next time